hundreds of thousands of sexual assault
survivors are sharing their stories on
social media about why they did not
initially report their attack chessy
proud and her mother Susan became
advocates for survivors after Jessi was
sexually assaulted by a classmate owen
labrie four years ago
that case involving the prestigious st.
Paul School in New Hampshire in the 2015
trial drew national attention this
year's Susan and chessy proud co-founded
the organization I have the right to it
aims to raise awareness about the
prevalence of sexual assault in high
schools and the need for education and
consent the group also helps survivors
know their rights and how to exercise
them
Susan Prout joins us at the table to
discuss Susan I'm very glad you're here
so sorry it's under these circumstances
because I would imagine that this brings
up such painful and terrible memories
for your family you wrote in a co-ed
this week that your daughter struggled
with guilt and shame and she was not
believed so I want to know what your
family the toll it's taking on the
family and what your message is today as
you sit here four years later well thank
you Gayle for having me today
indeed sexual assault takes us whole on
a whole family it's affected how we live
where we live where we work and and how
we support Jessie our daughter as a
survivor so it's that needs to be known
in the public we very very much believe
that we still have a rape culture and
we'd like to try and shift that to a
survivor inform culture where people
understand that after murder sexual
assault is probably one of the most
egregious heinous crimes against a human
being
mm-hmm talk about Jessie's experience
because I talked to someone who had a
was involved in sexual assault much
later in life and was afraid to talk
about it with her parents for fear that
they would worry about her that bond
between Cha daughter and parent is as a
complicated one how how was explaining
your experience with that I'm glad you
asked that
my advice to parents listening today is
to be a strong grounded parent who can
be available to your child if they come
to you
eh with the story of their account of
sexual assault we can't fall apart we
need to help move the needle forward for
our survivors so that their voices are
heard and that justice in whatever form
feels comfortable for them can be
pursued and one thing that was
interesting in my conversations about
this is that you say not fall apart but
then also don't smother and suggest that
because this has happened to you you are
somehow weak you somehow can't
participate in the rest of a functioning
life
I hope chessy has been able to show that
through writing her memoir about her
experience I have the right to that she
has not fallen apart people need to
support survivors but not take the lead
sexual assault as a crime of power you
need to give the power back to their
survivors do you worry now especially
after looking at this week how people
are vilified when they come forward do
you worry now that people will be
reluctant to come forward is that a
concern absolutely it's been a roller
coaster of emotions this week but I
fervently hope that survivors out there
watching these proceedings don't retreat
we need to keep activating the voices of
survivors and encouraging people to
share their stories however they're
comfortable and to educate our culture
on how to have a survivor informed
response next time rather than vilifying
and the first thing people do is to
question the veracity of a survivor
story jesse was bullied and vilified by
the school was she not she was and it
was shocking to us because it was a
beloved community to my family to my
husband who's a graduate to my older
daughter as well
how was she bullied in vilified what
exactly happened well I'll never forget
the rector at the times remarks that
when we talked about a plan for chessy
to return to st. Paul's after her salt
he said don't worry people would be too
busy to care very much about this which
is that was actually shocking to us as a
family because it had completely upended
our lives and chesties life of course so
they did more than ignore her they
actively supported the perpetrator by
raising funds they called it an incident
didn't they
yes actually that was the Board of
Trustees to this day still after all
Jesse's availed herself to the criminal
process she's gone through you know a
trial we've gone through a civil suit
and he still calls it an incident and
what do you think about dr. Ford today
how she must be feeling you know this is
a woman who was very private really
she's already admitted that she's
terrified she's walking into a room of
strangers and really unveiling herself
to all of us
about a very personal and painful
incident in her life well first of all I
just want to say it doesn't matter how
many years it takes for survivor to find
her voice I'm so proud of dr. Ford I
thought of her last night as I was
trying to go to sleep I'm sure she
didn't sleep at all last night it is you
know it's it's so important to own your
voice when you can because the trauma
never goes away
it's always there I've talked to 80 year
old survivors who've disclosed for the
first time so we are with dr. Ford today
and and no she's already succeeded by
coming forward all right Susan proud
thank you so much for sharing your and
Jesse's story with Miss Tate it